hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts vimeo therapy can see of
cancer using genetically enhanced T
cells t-cells I am Christina Mihalik of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational webinar presented
by laboratory announcements before we
begin this webcast is the design to be
interactive so we encourage you to ask
questions during the events you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green a Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can also enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit the
problem through the green Q&A button
once again located in the lower left
corner this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after look the webinar
is over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of the web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Michael Malone assistant professor of
pathology and laboratory medicine at the
hospital the University of Pennsylvania
associate director director toxicology
laboratory University of Pennsylvania
Perelman School of Medicine dr. Malloy
received his MD and
HD in experimental pathology in 1999
from Rutgers New Jersey Medical School
formerly known as the University of
Medicine of dentistry of new jersey
after an internship in internal medicine
at the hospital of the University of
Pennsylvania he completed postgraduate
medical training in clinical pathology
transfusion medicine a lavatory
toxicology following clinical training
dr. Malone pursued postdoctoral research
training in cancer immunology and
adopted India therapy with dr. Carl June
at the University of Pennsylvania where
he performed basic research to develop
CTL 019 a genetically modified t-cell
therapy for beak cell leukemia and
lymphoma that has been licensed by a new
virus in undergoing early phase clinical
testing he is currently an assistant
professor of pathology and laboratory
medicine at the University of
Pennsylvania School of Medicine at
present dr. Malone's laboratory is
focused on T cell biology in the
development of new techniques for
culturing culturing and genetically
modifying t lymphocytes for adopted a
new therapy of cancer I will now turn it
over to dr. Malone for his presentation
dr.
so thank you chris christie hopefully
everyone everyone hear me so before I
become I just need to you know it was it
just close closer from so as I think
shown on the initial disclosure slide do
have have some property righty right and
license to the horn apart I'm have
received royalties also though my
laboratory receives meaning for research
from navarre board as well as from other
mothers as shown on this slide and and
all these conflicts are managed in
accordance with the University of
Pennsylvania policy and oversight I'm so
to begin I think no I want to you know
how strict point that idea of using the
immune system to control because there
is really not a not a new idea I'm its
idea that has been around for over a
century you know with some of the new
euro work from a you know scientists
like William William folio surgeon New
York City who you know made the
observation in the 1800 spirits early
900th that some pain patient with cancer
they were in fact affected with a Patera
you know bacterial infection exhibited
spontaneous regression their tumor isms
he spent many years true to sort of you
know recapitulate that as a therapeutic
approach mostly sleep successfully
however ever the approach if scheana did
too probably give of what what many
people will be recognized which is a
vesicular BCE therapy for a transitional
self course and Alton almost similar
kind of kind of using bacterial since
the stimulated inflammatory response for
an anti anti key benefit the idea that
cancer answer actually be you know
regulated and that we might actually
prove that cancer I'm on a ruler basis
through immunity um is also is also not
India I'm that tonight that
was worth as you can see here in you
know probably over 50 years ago by for
example in parlin Brunei hey who
hypothesized that when individuals that
are you know developing titanius
Haitians and changes engineer somatic
cells that could lead to malignity that
they're something isn't prevented and
like we know you know certainty that
there are you know mechanisms to call
that at a DD and level back this of
course that's where we go Bell prizes
you know last year's Nobel Prize you
know with with medicines focused on that
on that but um you know he put out the
hypothesis that maybe even mean
illogical maxwell's might be a play play
to do do this and I think many many
years people strive to demo demonstrate
is some you know you know with a lot of
conflicting data SS you know decade they
really think we have give you know
become to understand that immunotherapy
can infant have benefits it's in cancer
um so when you think of the bat-beam
system first question you have to think
about that is this is the immune system
torque so in most cases wall are into
self and he needs something magnet you
differentiate tumor from a host in a way
you know brunette head I popped a zit
maybe see some of the etic changes he
does that occur when these tumors where
is my provide with that I mean I mean I
think past you know be ten years
next-gen sequencing we've really really
weak to really understand the landscape
of genetic mutant you tape and cancer
and they shown a slide you can see that
answer is really really running one
range of you know the numbers of somatic
mutations within their genome with a
chaotic melanoma Adam highest numbers
mutation per megabase verse for example
of a genome same thing for lung cancer
and whereas other tumors for example
ample if he left neuroblastoma and it
can acute you know leukemias and have a
much lower her humor bird
rotational burden and so really really
their range and even within some of the
high tumor from a burden as high to
mutation and diseases like Matt Miller
there's a wide range with some having
were hundreds hundreds of mutations
where there is having you know you know
a couple that might be horrible so we
know pitchers can in fact be Natalie
immunogenic you know and this is formed
the basis of cancer vaccines targeting
some of these chains and an addition to
those mutations there's been a lot
effort to try to look at tumor-specific
you know is to tumor expose antigens
such such as the and reenact seen a CIPA
loose tea or the gp120 vaccine
tumor-associated ians but not
necessarily specific to the tumor but i
think what real real that you know shows
us the benefit of potential tumor
immunotherapy RP is that immune
checkpoint eaters which gotten a lot of
attention recently melanoma and einon's
multiple cancer i'm really going
dramatic a effects on a cancer is like
no no no in non-small long answer um but
i think an important thing to recognize
is that again the nature of those
antigens and what you target may be it
may Britt achill to the statistics of
those therapies and in these two studies
I'm in the past two years that a photo
folks are looking at the relationship
between mutational burdens any outcomes
of check blockade I may be a very
apparent that the checkpoint point
blades really really rare hi mutational
Werdum 22 and a source of an advantage
to really provide that was at recess and
so you know it raises a question a
better be low anjin motional burden
diseases could actually be Cecily
targeted with era peas on that this is
you know of several barrel beds and not
old tumors
we would even have high mutational
burdens looks like we're having some
issues so i guess i'm rafe you ready i
can cancel a the i am hopefully audio yo
is there
hold on one second we're dealing with
technical each one second we're doing
with check alloys once activated
hopefully this is a better now for the
audio and I think we should be good to
go all right so going on to the next
slide here so so in addition to that
mutational burden that you know may not
be you may not have the mutations
necessary to target the cancers I mean
if there's many other barriers that we
faced with with cancer immunotherapy so
we know tolerance mechanisms which is
one of the checkpoint molecules for
example ctla-4 probably targets the
regulatory t-cell but there are many
other checkpoints and modulators that
such as myeloid suppressor cells that
inhibit the inflammation within tumors
and blocked tisa tumor immunity and then
of course when we do a cancer
chemotherapy on patients we induce a lot
of immunosuppression from the nature of
the drugs that we give patients and then
of course tumors acquire many local
properties that further help them abate
immunity such as alterations in their
ability to present tumor antigens so
even if there are mutations within those
tumors they can't present as well as
disruption of normal immune cell
migration and activation through
expression and modulation of chemokines
and creation of you know other barriers
for example physical barriers such as
the stromal elements that were or within
tumor and so when we think about this on
what my research lab in our group here
at Penn and I think several other groups
around the country in the world really
have begun to think about how do we get
beyond these the limitations of the
natural immune system which clearly if
cancer has succeeded and if it really is
being held in check normally in both
cases by the immune system and when you
get cancer clearly that was indicate a
failure of the immune system that we
might need something beyond
the natural and to use an analogy that I
think it's helpful is thinking about you
know performance-enhancing drugs in
sports and so you take this analogy of
Barry Bonds you know baseball player
from from Oakland you can see you know
in this graph here of his slugging
average illustrating how you know over
the years with it improved you know
training reach some plateau and his
flunking average but really improved
beyond what he was naturally able to
achieve through the use of you know
basically performance-enhancing drugs
and so you can think of it as a bit of
putting the immune system on steroids we
really need to find ways to get beyond
what is natural be capable and this is
where I think the chimeric antigen
receptor technology that I'm going to
mostly talk about really provides one of
the you know methods to do that so to
really take what is a very complicated
system and digest this data it's a
hopefully something that is at least
relatively simple you can think of the
t-cell receptor complex which is how we
naturally recognize antigens as this
very complicated receptor but comprised
of two components one is the t-cell
receptor that recognizes antigen and in
the case of the t-cell receptor it makes
its recognition through the MHC the
major histocompatibility complex and
peptides derived from cellular proteins
that are presented on the MHC and then
delivers its signal through a variety of
molecules but one that is is probably
sufficient is the cd3 zeta chain so the
other chains are not functional you can
still get a functional t-cell receptor
with just a CD 3 beta chain and but we
know that the T cells in order to
generate an AB a really robust immune
response it requires additional signals
beyond that so co-stimulatory receptor
signals like cd28 and these have to be
you know necessary to really get the
cytokine secretion the proliferation and
survival of those critical T cell phones
and to mediate the killing of target
cells what we tried to do with a
chimeric antigen receptor is essential
we take that complex t-cell receptor
complex and co-stimulatory receptor and
really simplify it into a single you
know molecule that could be expressed
within a t-cell that would have the
antigen recognition capability as well
as the signalling and this is done all
in a single molecule which you know
actually amazes me every day that this
enormously complex t-cell receptor
co-stimulatory system can be
recapitulated at some level by this
synthetic molecule but nonetheless it
works and through the use of monoclonal
antibody technology where we can now
essentially make antibodies to proteins
largely within a week perhaps even less
through contin you know approaches like
phage display we could take eventually
in the antibody molecule the two what
are depicted in this diagram as the
purplish variable domains the variable
heavy in the variable light you can
combine them into a single molecule
called a single chain variable fragment
that we can then link up to this
chimeric receptor the car and now we
have the capability of really conferring
the specificity of T cells under the
control of a defined antibody
single-chain FB and if now allows us to
one generate very rapidly in a cars to
almost any target that we would want to
target them to of course the car
approach does have a fundamental
difference from the t-cell receptor
which we can also clone from if we know
we have tumor-specific TCR as we could
theoretically clone those t-cell
receptor than many individuals are doing
this but the difference is that the core
actually allows us to target beyond just
simple proteins we can target non
protein antigens for example ganglia
side so there's been cars made against
the g2g d2 ganglia side that's expressed
in neuroblastoma as well as more
recently are one of the groups here at
ten generated a car targeting a mutation
that in cosmic that leads to an abnormal
black oscillation of muc1 and so these
are kind of change
that the t-cell receptor could not do
the one limitation though is that the
t-cell receptor require a surface
expression I'm sorry the car requires
that the target beyond the surface of
the targets of the tumor cell whereas
the t-cell receptor can in fact pretty
much sample the entire proteome of the
tumor so they are different but
complementary approaches and so how do
we implement this type of artificial
receptor in a adoptive t-cell
immunotherapy so I'm going to basically
show in this next slide what the general
approaches to using these therapies so
we start with a patient who we can
collect T cells from using procedures
very analogous dialysis known as a for
rhesus where we can collect on the order
of billions of lymphocytes from an
individual we can do you know gene
transfer into these cells and what we
use at the university of pennsylvania's
or lentiviral vectors which are hre HIV
derived gene therapy vectors however
people have done this with retroviral
vectors and there's also a lot of work
looking at ways to use non vector-based
gene transfer such as electroporation of
RNA into t cells transposons and even
now work efforts to use gene editing
approaches to introduce cars into T
cells we can then take those cells if we
have a billion lymphocytes we can expand
those ex vivo degraded in 10 to the 11
cells using ex vivo expansion and then
reinfect for folks who are not really
immunologist 10 to the 11 cells is
approximately what you have in your body
right now and we can take that whole
entire a number of t-cells and redirect
their specificity for towards a single
target antigen giving us a tremendous
amount of cytotoxic potential so this
next slide really it serves to just make
a fundamental point for those who are
used to thinking about traditional drugs
and I think you know the car T cell is
very different from most drugs that you
could think of in that it's a living
drug and so what's shown in this image
is basically a car T cell targeting
cd19 and the green cells represent tumor
cells that are expressing cd19 and that
cd19 in fact is tagged with a gfp marker
I mean you can see how it the T cell
clusters at cd19 at the interface where
the car is interacting with that cell
and then very soon after that
interaction the t-cell delivers the
death signal and that cell starts to
undergo a pathetic cell death and so
what's important is that these pieces
these are living cells that have the
ability to replicate and therefore give
pharmacokinetics that put that in
quotations that it may be very different
from any other type of pharmacokinetics
you might think about for a traditional
drug be that a biologic or a small
molecule so as we're developing this
we're thinking about what would be the
ideal target for a car and I think you
know the list is you know a sort of
three characteristics that we think are
probably going to be necessary to use
this technology successfully and safely
his number one the as I mentioned
earlier the target has to be expressed
on the cell surface number two the
target has to be expressed in all tumor
cells because we can expect that if it's
not an old tumor cells you'll get
selection and number three it needs to
be absent from normal tissues and the
reality is as far as I am aware there's
not a single target antigen that we're
currently pursuing that meets all of
these criteria but at the time I think
our group and many other groups realize
that probably the best sort of you know
starting point for this kind of
technology that really you know at least
a phablet meets two of the three
criteria at least we thought is cd19
until cd19 is a molecule that is
restricted to the B cell lineage so it's
not absent from normal tissues but it is
you know pretty much restricted to the B
cell alone and no other cell type within
the body it comes up very early in V
cell development and then spans the
entire range of differentiation of be
felt even to the terminal plasma cell
stage where it does get down regulated
if we have populations of plasma cells
that are positive and negative for cd19
but of course all malignancies that
arrived from be so well
retain this expression more or less
providing us now with an antigen that we
can theoretically and it's on the
surface of the cell that we can target
b-cell leukemias and b-cell lymphomas
and while it's not absent from normal
tissues we would expect it to target the
normal b-cell the other thing that we
knew is that normal b-cells if
individuals have genetic defect for
example in you know a congenital
bruton's agammaglobulinemia where they
don't have normal b cells people can
live relatively you know normal lives
with ivg IVIG immunoglobulin replacement
making the toxicity at least we thought
manageable so just want to point out as
I mentioned earlier T cells require
multiple signals a signal one which
delivers that sort of necessary signal
to activate the t-cell and deep in
closet degranulation and it also is
necessary for proliferation but it's not
sufficient so it's necessary but not
sufficient for full t-cell proliferation
which is what we think is necessary to
get large numbers of these cells so I
think we knew that there we need
co-stimulation unfortunately as shown on
this right-hand panel is that there is a
very large range of different molecules
that can deliver those sort of signals
and on the next slide you can see that
as we've got over generations of cars
that really you know it's been a largely
empiric approach but comparing different
cars with different signaling domains
that you know there are many ways that
one could make a car we chose the focus
very early on looking at the cd28 which
we know is a very critical
co-stimulatory signal and then the form
of vb co-stimulatory signal which is
part of the TNF super super family of
receptors that is necessary for survival
and we know memory in cd8 t-cells but
then there are also third generation
combining these multiple receptors that
these multiple co-stimulatory domains as
well I don't have time in this
presentation to really go into why we
chose a 4 DB domain that's in these
published papers but you know both cd28
and for
second generation cars for cd19 are
actually both being developed by many
different groups and companies and I
think you know which one is the superior
one I think there's still you know waits
to be answered but as I mentioned we put
forward for we being largely because of
what we demonstrated in a preclinical
setting of it improved persistence of T
cells in a leukemic model so we
initiated these trials and the first
patient we treated with this was a
patient with CLL and we did that I think
in part because CLL is a you know in a
subgroup of patients can be very
aggressive is very highly cd19 positive
and in general you know we also thought
about a tooth lymphoblastic leukemia but
bone marrow transplant is used quite
frequently there and we felt in the
early phase to start at least CLL was a
better disease to begin to do this we
completed the first 14 patients which
was reported in the last year and you
can see from this slide and I apologize
unfortunately it seems the color got
changed to white hopefully everybody can
see that but you know basically we we
treated a population of patients who are
relatively high risk in their disease
characteristics and in this cohort of
patients see an overall response rate of
about fifty seven percent with a
complete response rate of twenty eight
percent and a partial response rate of
twenty eight percent so put that
together to get your 57 with a almost
you know forty forty percent of patients
non-responsive and I think what we
learned from this study I'm is shown on
the next slide is that really as we
suspected from the preclinical data that
long-term persistence and expression
really does is an important
characteristic for for this therapy is
so shown here is in a series of plots
that are looking at the number of
genetic
vector copies per t-cell so this is a
marker basically of our of our engineers
t cells in the blood over time so time
is on the x-axis and this is a log scale
and you can see that very clearly i
think it's apparent that the first row
represents our complete responders those
are the four patients who showed a
complete response and then the patients
who are partial responders and then you
have the patients who are non-responders
on the bottom and it's pretty obvious
that the non-responders show very poor
overall engraftment i'm in the area
under those curves are much different
from the area under the curve for the
complete responders and the partial
responders and so why I think this this
is telling us it's really that you do
need that persistence and that in
grassman of these cells to mediate the
effect so it would be analogous to a
form of food to a small molecule where
if you're not giving the drug and the
drugs is not really there with
sufficient concentrations you don't get
the effect we've moved on to other
indications and what I'm going to show
you in the next slide is our work with
up sorry and i just want to point out
that these cells can persist for a very
long time and so this is just showing
one of our patients with CLL who without
over several years where we were able to
show that number one the t cells are
persistent in those patients out to that
time point so even out to over a
thousand days we still have you no
detectable cd8 positive T cells in the
peripheral blood more importantly when
we take those cells and we actually test
them against t cells this is a
granulation sa and an assay for
stimulation of nipple and data as a
cytokine secretion of marker of t cell
activation that you can see the city if
you enter if you let those cells
interact with with a negative target
cell you don't really see much in the
way of regulation of what beta in or do
you see the granulation but when you
take them and mix them with cd19
positive target cells they be granulate
which is a marker of their cytotoxic
function and they are very abundantly
producing nick 1 beta showing that those
cells that are present are still
functional in the blood out to several
we've moved this on into additional
indications and probably our most
advanced sort of disease indication that
we have focused on mostly here at Penn
is in the acute lymphoblastic leukemia
setting and in fact we've done most of
that in pediatric AOL so this is showing
data from the first 59 refract
relapsed/refractory pediatric a location
where we're seeing patient we're seeing
a CR rate of about ninth of ninety-three
percent with a median follow-up at this
time point that I can show you of 12
months the important things to recognize
here is that we really haven't seen many
relapses no relapses at this time point
past one year however we do have
patients who obviously do relapse and I
will come back to that but I want to
point out that the response rates that
we see with this car or comparable at
least two other cars out there for
example the j car 017 that's reported
out of Seattle is showing you know a
similar type of greater than ninety
percent CRA as well as the little bit
lower in a ll setting for the kite cd19
however nevertheless we definitely see
I'm pretty good activity across
different cars in this disease setting
and I think the you know efficacy really
you know showing the persistence is
illustrated this is our poster child for
the therapy Emma Whitehead really was
the first child to receive this therapy
and she was you know fairly advanced in
her to these very short life expectancy
and you know I could say that now she is
over four years in no detectable cancer
with car t cells still you know
persistent and present showing the real
persistence of these cells so again
these efficacy though doesn't come
without toxicity
so I think to highlight and sort of
summarize the toxicity that has been
observed in these patients b cell
aplasia as we expected is a certainly a
toxicity it's observed in all responding
patients to date and currently is
managed with replacement therapy
basically IVIG tumor lysis syndrome is
another you know not unexpected when
patients have high tumor burden however
I think the thing to point out here is
that patients can have this hump tend to
have this complication and it can be
delayed so we have seen it anywhere from
20 even out as far as up to 50 days post
T cell infusion which is probably a
little bit wider range than you might
see with typical you know small molecule
chemotherapeutic drugs probably the
biggest most notable and the most talked
about toxicity is the cytokine release
syndrome and this is a you know
reversible you know toxicity that occurs
from on target activation of the T cell
when they engage cd19 positive target
cells they produce lots of cytokines and
we know that the severity of this
syndrome is related to the tumor burden
and what's important i think is that it
can be quite quite severe so it's it's
something that you know really I don't
think we expected until we've treated
patients to the degree that it can occur
and in many respects um you know as I
mentioned a lot of our patients our
pediatric ALL patients and our pediatric
hematologist oncologist Stephan Grupp at
chop Children's Hospital Philadelphia
you know it's really likened it to the
macrophage activation syndrome when you
look at these patients bone marrows you
can see a wrister of phagocytosis and it
really parallels a lot of the features
with incredibly high ferrets and levels
but what's important is that it is can
be reversed it appears with cytokine
blockade in particular il-6 so you know
our current strategies use tops alyssa
map to treat these patients and mo
whitehead was that first patient really
you know showed a dramatic
that was recorded in that paper I mean
the other big thing I think to consider
that we don't understand and didn't
expect was the neurotoxicity which in
these patients ranges from delirium
during the fever through Frank
encephalopathy with aphasia confusion
hallucinations it doesn't appear to
correlate with the crs severity and
doesn't appear to be prevented by us
ilysm f but it does appear to be
self-limiting and so when patients when
it resolved you know the patients
usually seem to recover fully from this
therapy so just closed a little bit more
of essence the cytokine release intro
because I think it is an important you
know and one of the challenges to really
broadly applying this therapy this is
this is actually the data from Emma
whiteheads the chopper 100 is our first
patient treated with this and you can
see that after receiving the cards from
day 0 that was in about three days she's
asleep again having you know
intermittent fevers to fairly high
levels levels that an adult you know it
would be quite severe and then a few
days after the spiking fevers you start
to see the cytokine SR the ldh rise
indicative of probably tumor lysis and
if you and when she started spiking
these fevers that she was getting some
you know degree of respiratory
hemodynamic instability we tried
steroids we tried blocking TNS using em
bro and unfortunately I think because of
pediatric of you no indication of
juvenile arthritis test Alyssa map was
actually on the formulary at Children's
Hospital and that was tried really the
last ditch effort and and it's quite
rumor Acula sleep they key from from the
you know way Steve grup describes it
within hours of her receiving tough
melissa met her fever resolved blood
pressure and most of her hemodynamic
parameters improved dramatically and
basically you can see here that much of
that clinical syndrome really is
associated with the spikes and keep in
cytokines
relief and we've definitely seen that
this pattern is very similar in CLL and
in am and I just point out in the point
to your attention that there has been a
grading system that has been developed
for for crs as well as recommendations
on when really to treat with
interventions such as test Alyssa map I
think we still you know it's still early
days with this therapy and I think we
you know are still exploring the range
of of when you can apply the Tuscaloosa
map and I'm hoping that there will be
trials to really look at even maybe
prophylactic use of tough to listen to
prevent cytokine release syndrome you
know since patients get it during the
peak of response still seem to have good
responses so as I mentioned this is just
showing the disease burden and it is
well correlated you know the rate for
high you know severe CRS is correlated
with the level of disease burden and
more recently you know I think in
efforts looking back at the cytokine
data trying to look at you know whether
there might be markers that might
predict patients who are going to go on
to have very severe CRS and I think this
is published data you can see here from
our experience in the AOL setting you
can see that we certainly can define a
few cytokine markers that can be applied
in the first three days of therapy that
have a fairly high sensitivity and
specificity for severe CRS unfortunately
we currently lack clinically validated
methods to measure all these cytokines
and the other big challenge is even
within that three day period you know
these patients often can progress to a
very severe CRF fairly rapidly as to
whether you get the rapid clinical
turnaround necessary to use it is
unclear and I think that's where I think
prophylactic or early intervention
studies really needs to be done the
other thing I need to discuss is really
the mechanisms of resistance so we know
as I mentioned that we can get greater
than ninety percent of patients into a
plete response in both pediatric and
adult AOL however 15 of our first 50
patients treated with AOL went on to
relapse and we know that ten of these 15
patients relapse with cd19 negative
leukemias this was a day I talked about
this earlier that CD 90 do we thought it
was going to be a fairly good marker
definitely for CLL and for mature b-cell
malignancies they pretty much uniformly
expressed it we did have this concern
with CLL that I mean ALL that a ll
patients can have you know it can vary
not all whales actually Express cd19 and
so it may be a result of the you know
the fact that cd19 comes on around the
time you know when we think da ll sort
of lignin cells arise from that that
state of B cell maturation nonetheless
we know that we had ten relapses and so
I think the question is what are the
mechanisms of City 19 negative relapse
and a ll and so in exploring that we
have seen that there are a couple of
different ways surprisingly most of
these al seem to still maintain cd19
expression however it seems the dominant
ways of acquiring this resistance really
are through two mechanisms one is a
splicing mechanism where we know that
the epitope that we're targeting by the
car which is derived from the fmc 63
cd19 clone targets exon 2 predominantly
of cd19 and so there is at least a
couple of cases of splicing that
occurred that removes basically that
exon 2 presumably disrupting and we know
the epitope but we know that sells we
introduce this splice variant into cells
they are they're not sensitive to cd19
to the CTL 019 car product mutations
have also been identified in both the
exon 2 and X on 4 and we believe that
these may be hot spots that may be
necessary for the antibody binding to
the
domains so many different trials have
now looked at this this is my attempt at
summarizing most of those trials here
but you can see that really cd19 is
being used quite widely with different
signaling domain so as I mentioned the
two dominant signaling domains of the
cd28 in the form BB however I think
there are also trials now looking at
even other types of signal domains in
this setting so I guess I want to move
on you know and look at how can we
expand this technology beyond cd19 so
certainly I think you know it works
quite robustly in cd19 malignancies but
you know can we expand this to other
target antigen so one of the antigens
that we're pursuing is the molecule BCM
a or b cell maturation antigen this is a
molecule that is expressed on mature B
cells pretty much memory a subset of
memory mature B cells but it is very
highly expressed by plasma cells and
it's actually thought to be important
for maintaining plasma cell homeostasis
and much like cd19 this this this
molecule bcma doesn't seem to have
expression anywhere outside of the B
cell lineage so as a logical extension
to cd19 I thought we think this Mia
maybe you know one that will have a lot
of similarities to the cd19 molecule and
so this first in human clinical trial
was actually performed by Jim Koch
endure from folks at the NCI which was
reported this past summer with the
reference below in blood and they show
that they could take 12 patients and
they treated them with a range of cell
doses and really at the highest cell
doses where they saw their effects and
they have one stringent see our lasting
12 weeks as well as to be GPR so we have
also been developing this target have a
clinical trial open
and and one of the things that we're
looking at in this trial which I think
differentiates us a little bit is the
question of whether we need lintel
depleting chemotherapy so we have in
this trial built in three cohorts of
patients a first cohort that is actually
receiving these cart cells without
little depleting chemotherapy which is
so what you know contentious I think in
the field and most I think would argue
and actually the neurotoxicity
associated with the cd19 car that was
reported and caused the halt in the Juno
trial was you know thought to be at
least associated perhaps with the
fludarabine little depleting
chemotherapy we thought it's important
to ask the question do we need this limp
will depleting chemotherapy so we
decided to build this into our clinical
trial along with them two cohorts that
receive the cytoxan we didn't use
fludarabine in this setting because we
were concerned about the toxicity in the
myeloma patients who are often feel
depleted already and then this is an
error here i just want to point out on
cohort to we're looking at a lower dose
of cells and then a higher dose similar
to what we're using in cohort one so
this trial has been open and we've been
recruiting this design as i mentioned is
very similar to how we do most of our
car trials where we do in a paresis
collect the self manufacture patients
get the cytoxan day minus three if
they're in the cohort that's going to
get that and then are receiving and
we've also decided in most of our car
trials to actually do a split dosing
strategy where we give ten thirty and
sixty percent with the idea that you
know if we give ten and thirty percent
and then patients on day two start to
develop fever we don't really want to
fuel the fire by putting more card cells
into that patient so we felt that is
what those might actually help to
prevent the severe cytokine release
syndrome and then we do the follow-up as
indicated what i can tell you and report
and we'll be reporting this at least
first cohort of patients for one at the
ashby
December is that the pharmacokinetic the
engraftment of t-cells that we see in
this setting looks comparable to what we
are seeing in patients with CTL 019 and
just to show you you know one patient
group that we've disclose which is a
patient who had a fairly aggressive
disease is a 66 year old male but 11
prior lines of therapy progressing on
his last therapy had bone marrow with
seventy percent involvement you can see
the genetic there and this patient
received basically two times ten to the
eighth court cells no lymph with the
pleading chemotherapy and he developed a
grade three crs that responded quite
nicely to tuscaloosa map and you can see
on the rightful robust engraftment of
his heart cells reaching as high as
ninety-five percent of his peripheral
blood on t cells at the peak of the
response you can see on the lower left
you know that those cells are car
positive this is a day 7 you know quite
robust expansion same things shown by
the qpcr quantitative PCR results
including parallel in the bone marrow
quite high level T cell engraftment in
this patient went on to really you know
show flow cytometry this is showing his
day 28 bone marrow where the malignant
clone that's shown in that upper left
you know gate really is a you know
undetectable in this flow this patient
has done on and actually I should say is
actually beyond the GPR is now in a
stringent CR I think I forgot to update
this life but basically you can see here
the kinetics really of his EM spike
declining which is probably
representative more or less of his
antibody clearance and the reductions in
his green light chain as well as your mm
spike so just in the final few minutes
how do we expand this beyond team
malignancies so as I mentioned lots of
different efforts everybody is working
on CD
teen more and more people were working
on bcma what about solid tumors lots of
antigens being developed including at
our institution at 10 and I think one of
the big challenges in solid tumors is as
I alluded to from the beginning is
really target selection target is
important and so we are you know you
know sort of you know very cognizant of
these early studies with cars including
the top one here in the 2006 which was a
first generation no co-stimulation card
targeting carbonic anhydrase nine that
was bought to be restricted to renal
cell carcinoma but you know was you know
these patients went on to develop you no
evidence of biliary sort of targeting
did a very low level expression of this
and then this has been observed with her
too in terms of ur B 2 and then even in
targeting things like CEA you know in
colorectal cancer so target restriction
is important so we've been looking at
measles feeling carts I'm going to just
show you we move this forward this is
all published but you know essentially
showing again that we can target this
this is with with hopefully we can hear
me oh sorry that's not directly to me so
the just showing that we can in fact
make a co stimulated car that works the
challenge with this is that measles
feelin is expressed by normal tissues
and we knew that going in it's expressed
on normal meisel figlio cells that line
the pleura the pericardium and the
peritoneum but it is expressed on a
range of different cancers including
ovarian pancreatic and measles paloma so
we've actually done a phase 1 clinical
trial using these lentiviral engineered
cells we also did a non stable
transfection based approach initially
with this and this is just showing busy
sort of interim results for this is
meisel feeling trial but you can see
unlike what i showed you for the cd19
car the levels of engraftment here in
the blood neither again vector copies
per micro gram of blood are you know
orders of magnitude lower engraftment
than what we see in the cd19 or bcma
setting and even with setup cytoxan for
little depletion it certainly enhances
the level of engraftment to some extent
but still nowhere near the level of
engraftment we haven't seen much in the
way of effect two partial responses in
our initial cohort of six patients and
we have you know basically you know
considered some possibilities we haven't
seen long-term persistence we are using
a murine single chain FV for this and so
one of the efforts is to try to switch
just to a human cdna human sorry a
single human single chain FV because
perhaps immunogenicity which has been
shown to be important in some cars could
be playing a role but i think the other
challenge is that in solid tumors mrs.
work that we've been collaborating with
steve albelda here at the university of
pennsylvania's working in measles ely
oma then in this preclinical model of
mesothelioma you can see that when you
put these T cells into this model well
they can have a modest effect on the
tumor duty so ultimately become hypo
functional and cease functioning over
time and so this loss of function is
something that I think we need to spend
a lot more effort into understanding
some of it may be related to new check
points and regulation like that but I
don't think we really understand these
mechanisms at all um and then I think
finally to end I just want to you know
talk about sort of you know the future
you know how you actually bring this to
patients right this one thing to do this
in a you know academic center I'm like
10 you know so we treated our first
patients with this in July of 2010
interview and the question is you know
we've only treated maybe you know a few
hundred patients at this point but how
do you treat thousands of patients a
year with this type of very complex
therapy
and I think you know this is one of the
challenges that you know hopefully over
the next few years we will figure out
whether we can do this but I think the
important thing that we recognize is
that you know really the existing sort
of biotech you know form a medical
device industry really has no experience
with this unique type of therapeutic
approach and that really it may be that
you need a separate sort of you know
area of global health care really around
cellular therapeutics they really are
very very different and in particular
some of the issues to think about it is
a very patient specific model unless
reversal sort of alginate cards can be
made to work and so every product is a
unique product and you know is
centralized manufacturing versus blood
bank sort of distributed manufacturing
the way to do this and I don't think we
know the answer to that yet the biotech
sort of you know industry has really
focused around a centralized
manufacturing approach currently we'll
see if that's successful but I think
we've certainly demonstrated that out
scaling and distributed manufacturing is
can be done and the first cell therapy
basically t-cell therapy if you think
about it is bone marrow transplantation
and we've been able to do millions so
there is a way to deliver this you know
if it can be successful the other
challenge is it's quite expensive you
know and complex to manufacture these
and I think we can learn and then this
is an area's I think that's going to be
very heavily you know explored in the
future is can we learn from you know
right now we're making I kind of used
the Lamborghini analogy it's a very
highly customized handmade product right
now and can we really twitch just to
afford model where we can actually do
automated manufacturing that would
probably be not only more efficient but
also perhaps even more consistent and so
with that I'll just have to acknowledge
the many many people who have been
involved in these studies you know takes
a village to do this particularly Carl
June and David Porter Steve grew up noel
fry these are the clinical investigators
who really have pushed forward with
these studies and Adam Cohen in our bcma
trial and then Bruce Levine is really
pioneered a lot of the
I thank the patients you know who are
really brave enough to volunteer for
these first and human studies both
adults and children and with that I get
both to the questions okay thank you so
much doctor thank you for that in one
informative presentation before we get
started on the question intercession I
would like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit the
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which is located in the bottom left hand
corner of your screen will try to answer
as many questions that possible and
let's see we're still so we'll wait a
moment to see if anyone has a question
coming in but dr. do you have any final
comments lieu of any questions that you
you just like to get out final comments
I think I comment it enough happily a
question okay well over there looks like
there are no more questions for today
and once again like to thank you dr.
Malone for your presentation today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through februari 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to Ford this
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's event see you next
time once again this is christina from
laborat have a great day